so good morning everybody and thanks for
organizing this great workshop so my
perspective on cancer is very much from
an evolutionary point of view so I will
talk about this in the next 20 or 30
minutes or so so we'll very simplified
terms the way we think of cancer as an
evolutionary process is that the first
change occurs in a single cell maybe
mutation may be a methylation change and
this change gives a selective advantage
to the cell it will expand replicate
more successfully than the neighboring
cells and while it is doing so
additional mutations will accumulate
several clones come up here and
eventually this process may lead to the
formation of cells that can leave the
tissue of origin and that might also at
some point be able to see it metastasis
so tumors in new organs that's the the
very simple way I look at this process
basically now the common model for this
is a series of clonal expansions so each
I expand each driver mutation so each
mutation that gives a selective
advantage is indicated by a star here
again starting from a single normal cell
and then these clones grow the increase
in their size and while they're doing so
additional driver mutations occur so if
you look at a single point in time and
such a tumor it might be fairly clonal
but it might also be the case that there
are several clones coexisting at a
certain point in time and of course if
you look at the following time point the
constellation of the different clones
their frequencies and their genetic
makeup might have changed so in general
there is a lot of diversity in tumors a
lot of heterogeneity that has been
described between different tumors from
different patients even for the same
histological tumor type for some time
and a lot of work has been done on the
level also of RNA here also on the level
of DNA and a little more recently people
started looking more closely into
individual tumors and it turns out that
there's also
a large intra tumor heterogeneity so if
you look into the individual cells of a
single tumor it turns out they are
different genetically they can have
different transcriptional profiles and
at the end of the day have different
phenotypic properties so there's a
number of challenges in analyzing this
situation and this is just my my short
favorite list here mutation calling of
course has been the topic of church talk
this morning and even snv calling for a
mixed tumor is not a solved problem it
is for clonal mutations but not so for
low frequency mutations then we would
like to understand what these mutations
are doing so we want to predict the
phenotypic effect of mutations and then
we would like to understand what the
evolutionary history of a tumor is we
would like to reconstruct the events
that have given rise to the tumor as we
observe it in a sample that we're taking
today and eventually we also want to
predict cancer evolution as much as we
can if it is predictable and the
progression of the tumor this is in
particular interesting under the
Selective pressure of treatment of
therapies of drug the treatment for
example because you would like to
understand what your chances are of
treating a patient treating a tumor
successfully so I will focus very much
on this third topic but also a bit touch
upon the fourth and in a way of the
second one and what I will show you is
sort of two recent studies that we have
done one looking at intra - modularity
and more precisely reconstructing
phylogenetic tree models for a single
tumor and the second topic will be about
a class of moles that are sometimes
called uncle genetic models sometimes
are tumor progression models where the
idea is to learn something about the
dependencies of the genetic events and
the observed samples typically from
different tumors are regarded as
independent observations of that process
so by contrast the phylogenetic problem
is that you have a set of samples
characterized by let's say genetic
alterations and you you want to make a
statement about their relationship
about the evolutionary history of this
sample so the problems are in in a way
related and there has been a lot of
previous work of course on both of these
topics and I apologize for not
mentioning any of these other ones that
focus in the in the short time given
here on the new models that we have
designed so starting then with phylogeny
reconstruction the model we constructed
is called site tree inference for single
cell data and this is work that has been
done by katerina yong and jay culpers
and both of them are here at the
workshop this week so the starting point
is we're looking at the development of
such a tumor and simple terms here again
the driver mutations time runs from the
top to the bottom and we're taking a
sample now at this at the current time
point here of individual cells from the
tumor and we assume that we have single
cell sequencing data so the data idly
looks like this the roles are index by
mutations the columns are index by cells
and the one here simply indicates that
the mutation is present in this
particular cell and the 0 means the
mutation is not present now in reality
especially the single cell sequencing
data will be noisy
so there will be false negatives there
will be false positives and there will
also be a typically a sizeable fraction
of sites that cannot be observed because
they have not been covered by the
sequencing and the amplification so
there is a large amount typically of
missing data in the sample so the goal
now is to reconstruct the evolutionary
history of these cells based on the
mutation profile so photogenic tree
might look like this the samples of the
cells label the leaves of the tree
imitations occur along the edges of this
tree so the assumption that is typically
made in this context and that we are
also making here's the infinite sites
assumption so each mutation kernel can
occur at most once over the entire tree
and then this gives rise to a perfect
fellow Janee and an alternative way to
represent the situation now
is by a mutation trees on the mutation
tree the vertices are labeled by
mutations and the cells are then
attached let's say each cells attached
to one of the mutations so these two
representations are completely
equivalent under the infinite sites
assumption and it just turns out that we
prefer this representation here for
doing inference later and forgetting at
the dependencies of the mutations that
we are really interested in so the way
you think of attaching the samples here
is you start from the root and if you
trace out the path here you pick up all
the mutations on the path and the cell
you are reaching at the leaf is exactly
characterized by that set of mutations
that occur on the paths on the unique
path to that cell in fact the in fact
the point of view we will take later on
is that we don't care about this
attachment too much anymore we're mainly
interested in the dependencies of the
mutations due to the observation noise
that we have here we might not be able
to sort out precisely where to attach
cells but the focus is really on
understanding the order in which
mutations occur rather than sorting out
exactly the relationship of individual
cells which might not be of such
interest in the first place so let me
show you the model for doing this
first of all there's a very simple model
for the observation error so here's the
I simplified the tree little further
here removing I didn't say this but
these two mutations are of course
uninformative you cannot distinguish so
I removed these two from the from the
data here and so the ideal data looks
like this three mutations and here are
seven single cells seven samples maybe
with some observation error and there's
simply a parameter for the false
positive rate and another one for the
false negative rate that gives you the
probability of switching such a bit so
that's a simple as it can get so now we
can write down the likelihood so assume
that we have n mutations and M samples
in our matrix the tree topology is noted
by T and then this vector Sigma accounts
for the attachment of the samples to the
tree so Sigma J component J tells me
where to place sample
at the tree at which mutation to attach
it the false positive and false negative
rates we denote by theta here and then
the likelihood simply factors over all
the mutations and all the samples and
just for each entry in the matrix I get
here the probability of the observed
data given the expected value from the
tree and the attachment of the samples
okay so that's the that's the likelihood
and then I can of course also look at
the posterior likelihood times the prior
and for the prior we would typically
assume that the attachments depend on
the tree structure and this part of the
prior here we typically design in such a
way that the attachment is independent
for each of the samples and I'll show
you in a second why that is important so
as I set the attachment of samples is no
more regarded as a noise ins parameter
and one way to deal with this is to
integrate it out so here's again the
posterior divided by this part of the
prior and if the if this prior is now
designed in such a way that it factors
over the individual samples then for
marginalizing out the attachment which
is a big sum over this vector Sigma so
any possible attachment you have to
consider this sum in general is too big
and hopeless to compute but it will
factor over the individual observations
such that you only have to sum for each
Sigma J and in this manner the
likelihood becomes becomes tractable and
becomes computable rather efficiently so
it's just linear and the product of the
number of mutations and the number of
observations okay with that we would
like to do inference either in the
maximum likelihood or in the in the
Bayesian fashion looking at the
posterior probability so first of all
again if you have n mutation and M
samples the full search space of this
problem is the number of labeled trees n
plus 1 to the power of n minus 1 treat
treat apologies are there and this would
be the number of attachments if you
wanted to optimize them and search
explicitly and this is just the two
continuous parameters from our error
rates now after integrating this part
here out you just left with the three
space and the two continuous parameters
of the arrow process and what we're
doing now is we're using an Markov chain
Monte Carlo approach in order to sample
from the three space and I will not go
into great detail here but the the main
idea is to use a prune and REE graft
step in order to move sub parts of the
tree and that will give you a Markov
chain that eventually will converge to
the posterior you want to sample from
okay let me show you two examples of
this approach the first one is a very
early single cell sequencing data set
from 2012 the authors here analyzed 58
cancer cells and there was a way to
select 18 of the observed mutations at
that point there was a large fraction of
missing data 45% and the authors already
estimated the error rates that was on
the order of 10 to the minus 5 for false
positive and very large over 40% oops
over 40% for the false negatives so data
matrix looks like this and everything
that's brown here is really missing as
missing data so the optimal tree I mean
we have a full sample from the posterior
but I will just show you one optimal
tree the maximum likelihood tree looks
like this and I'm labeling here each
mutation simply by the gene in which
that mutation occurred so these are all
gene name gene names and as you see the
structure of the tree is very linear
it's almost a linear chain except for
this one branching point down here so
you can also know after you have the
optimal tree you can ask again about the
optimal attachment of the samples if you
are interested in it
and turns out for this tree here there
is a lot of co-opt ml attachments let's
for example look at this one here s 19
so this is equally well attached to any
of these samples here for example or
this samples equally well attached to a
number of other samples and the reason
for so many Co optimal solution
here is that the data was very noisy a
lot of daters unobserved in fact and
nevertheless the structure of the
mutation tree so if you look at the red
vertices here that structure tends to be
very stable so the idea is really to
integrate out this noisy part here that
we might not care about too much because
after all these are only with individual
cells these are not different species
right so you don't probably really care
too much what exactly the nearest
neighbor of a single cell here is but
you do care about the mutation process
how do these mutation depend on each
other what was the order in which most
likely they have occurred okay looking
at a second example this is single cell
sequencing data of a breast tumor from
the lap of Nikki Nevel from 2014
so more recent and the technology has
improved so here 47 cells have been
analyzed 14 mutations selected only 1.4%
missing data and even lower false
positive rate 10 to the minus 6 and also
an improved force negative rate on the
order of of 10% so data matrix looks
like this and I would write the right to
jump into the optimal tree here looks
like this so again a fairly linear
structure here and then there's a
branching point and then there's a more
complex branching structure towards the
bottom of the tree with a number of
different alternatives the yellow nodes
here simply indicate known cancer driver
genes so the summary of situation is as
follows this is the same tree from the
previous slide and now I have grouped
together in this box the mutations that
we whose order we cannot distinguish
because there's only a single
observation here so there's no way of
telling the order among those mutations
so within the block here we don't know
the order of the mutations or let's say
there is no evidence in the data for it
and the attachment here is much more
stable in the sense that most cells are
attached only to a single mutation
because the data is less noisy so the
attachment also becomes clearer and the
basic interpretation is of course that
this linear part of the tree corresponds
to past clonal expansion that have
occurred
and they we happen to be lucky to see a
few cells here only that give us some
indication in which order they have
occurred in the past most of the
observations are attached towards the
bottom here so more recently then this
tumor has expanded into this larger
number of coexisting subclones and and
we can we care we have more confidence
in estimating the structure down here so
if you were to look at the same process
at a later time point data that we don't
have right now it's it's it's not clear
but it might be the case that one of
these lineages is selected for and the
linear chain would be simply extended
and the tumor would again branch out to
explore the fitness landscape okay
I would like to move on to the second
part so now I want to jump sure means
separate problem that may be a longer
discussion but I think it for this
specific data set the single cell
sequencing data the main point is that
the data is very noisy so there are
large false positive false negatives and
also a large number of missing data and
the standard for low Janee methods they
assume perfect data let's say the better
thing is the main is the main point at
this level the second thing is of course
that we are making this infinite science
assumption here which is also made in
other context but which makes it in a
way easier at this point
okay let me move on infrared side
standard just means that on autopilot
not on this but on a phylogenetic tree
in each mutation can occur at most once
so it cannot occur independently on on
different branches for example it cannot
be reverted either have you ever tried
comparing against deep sequencing deep
sequencing but not seeing it sir what we
have done is we apply to these data
methods that have been designed for
mixed samples which is in a way not
right they have not been designed for
this but just to see do they already do
the trick basically and they're not
performing as well as this method I can
show you comparisons if you want I
didn't put it into this presentation in
general of course maybe that's the the
the more important answer that problem
is a harder problem if you start from
the mixed sample and you have to
deconvolute and then want to reconstruct
the history in a way that this this data
was more informative so you expect to
get more out of it and what yeah
obviously this is a mixture of the
existing data if there could be things
that you're using haha
yeah I mean that's true of course if
your coverage is very deep and you can
pick up things at a at a frequency that
you don't of course it's a matter of how
deep to your sequence in the bulk and
how many cells do you have in a single
cell yeah we didn't you know quantify
this trade-off okay let me now jump to
the second part here so now the data I
mean in a way we look at the transpose
of the matrix but the focus is a
different one and the samples that we're
looking at are now not from a single
tumor but from different tumors so we
will regard them as independent
observations and we want to learn
dependencies of the mutations again but
now those dependencies that are shared
across different tumors so these are
like more general dependencies
that that we think will hold in any
realization of this stochastic process
so this is work by Simona Castilla and
also Jake Kuiper's and again both of
them are here this week and the tool is
called path time x and it will combine
the idea of finding pathways using a
mutual exclusivity argument and then
learning the dependencies among these
pathways so we will right from the
beginning think of these dependencies
not as dependencies between individual
genes but between pathways so for
modeling these dependencies we're using
a model that we have worked on for a
while and it's based on a partial order
so the idea is that we're trying to
extract partial constraints that are
shared among different tumors so think
of ABC and D as different groups of
genes different pathways and the post
set here indicates that you first need
to alter a pathway a and then you can
move on to C and D and actually D you
can only have if both a and B have been
altered so for example you might affect
F ups apoptosis first then you could
have angry Genesis and so on so that's
the way to think of this model now each
individual tumor is now a realization of
this process each individual tumors
still a series of clonal expansions but
the order in which these expansions
occur must be consistent with the
partial order that that the model
specifies in the beginning so there is
an explicit notion here of the time it
takes for a mutation to occur and of the
time at which you look at the sample the
time to diagnosis or the observation
time so again the ideal expected data
would look like this these are the
tumors these are the pathways that one
means it's also at a zero means it's not
and again in reality there will be false
positives and false negatives so again
we want to have a probabilistic model
for this the waiting times for these
mutations to occur simply follow
exponential distributions where each
group ABCD has an individual rate lambda
and the waiting process is in our set up
in such a way that for example if you're
waiting for mutation D
you'll first need a and B so the waiting
time is the maximum for mutations a and
B plus the individual contribution for D
so you're really waiting for things to
happen first and then you can move on so
it's a hard constraint in a way and the
sampling time we don't know so it's
again assumed to come from an
exponential distribution with another
parameter lambda s so as a probabilistic
graphical model it looks like this here
are the waiting times and these are the
dependencies among the waiting times
this is what we're really interested in
this would be the the the true genotype
but it's hidden we cannot observe it and
the observed genotype subject to noise
again it's down here so the time to
diagnosis gives rise to a sort of
censoring because you can see a mutation
of corn of course only if you looked at
the sample after it has occurred right
if you look too early basically the
mutation has not occurred yet so now let
me look at the mutual exclusivity
component and so the question is can we
find these pathways now de novo of
course the first approach might be to
say okay I take my favorite pathways and
I define a b c and d by my favorite list
of pathways and that's fine and you can
do it but the idea is not to combine
both things finding the pathways and
learning the dependencies among the
pathways so the pathway you want to find
as a group of mutually exclusively
mutated genes so the typical pattern
looks like this tumors are the rows and
genes are the columns and for each tumor
among this specific group of genes you
have at most one of the genes mutated so
you never or hardly see more than one
gene mutated and the interpretation is
then that any additional mutation here
would not give an additional selective
advantage to the cell and therefore
you're you're not or you're hardly
observing that so the main idea of this
model is again to look at the waiting
times and and and in order to see in
order to see a certain mutation pattern
it again depends how quickly these
mutations occur and what you observe
observation time is relative to that
process now for mutual exclusivity the
main idea is really if you look at its
a Pathan where you observed a single
mutation there's basically two reasons
why this might occur and the first one
that's the right part of this
probability is that this is not an
instance of mutual exclusivity 1 - Mews
the probability of not having much
exclusivity and then simply what
happened is the waiting time for that
mutation was smaller than the
observation time and that one was
smaller than the waiting time for all
the other mutations so in other words
that mutation just happened to occur
first okay and that's why we saw it the
second per second option and that is the
muchas cosas DT case is that that
mutation occurred first before
everything else but there's no
constraints on the observation time
relative to the other mutations in other
words the other mutations in general
will have had enough time to occur but
we don't see them and the reason we
don't see them is that they didn't reach
fixation because they didn't give a
selective advantage so that's exactly
what we call mutual exclusivity that's
the basic idea of this model and now
what we have done we combined the two
models the progression model from the
previous slide with this idea of mutual
exclusivity and this is the path time X
model and looks like this now you have
groups of mutations shown in the
different colors here and dependencies
among them so let's look at the green
one here so t8 for example would be the
waiting time for gene 8 and u3
is the pathway and gene 7 and gene 8 are
associated to this pathway so now we
have a notion of a waiting time for a
gene and the waiting time of a pathway
and in order for the pathway to be
altered you're simply waiting for the
first gene of that pathway to be altered
and whether you're observing or whether
let's say the true genotype would have
that mutation is simply a matter of
which of the mutations was first
relative to the observation time so same
idea as before so pathway is altered as
soon as one of these genes is altered
and the genes now depend on upstream
pathways rather than genes so all of
these genes here depend on the two
pathways that you need to have altered
before you can move on to the next
okay so in terms of inference it's
becoming a complex model now and we're
using an iterative procedure here in
which we learn yeah in an iterative
fashion the assignment of genes to the
pathways and then the dependencies among
the pathways and we iterate until we
converge and I show you two quick
examples the first one is on a on a
rather small colorectal cancer data set
only eight genes this is from 2007
so another large scale data set but the
progression in colorectal cancer is
quite well described it's compared here
to the textbook example from vogelstein
and indeed this is pretty much recovered
so APC k r s t p53 is your independent
so that order of mutations is pretty
much recovered here and then looking at
a more recent glioblastoma dataset from
TCGA starting here with a large number
of events the model eventually looked
like this so here are all these are the
different pathways this data set also
included deletions and amplifications
and you see that each box here is a
group of mutualist tools of genes so you
see these nice patterns of mutual
exclusivity and all of them and the
dependencies among them are indicated by
these edges here there's also a notion
of certain of uncertainty that we have
in these edges and turns out this
particular model was very stable okay
with that I would like to wrap up so for
the first part the three inference part
are called side software's available
here single cell sequencing data can be
used to reconstruct the evolutionary
history of individual tumors I hope I
could convince you of that and I showed
you to such intro to my fellow Chinese
that support an evolutionary model of
successive clone expansions in which
subclones coexist until one of them
reaches fixation the second part
software called path time X also
available here tumor evolution is
constrained by partial orders of gene
and pathway alterations so you we do
find these constraints in the data and
mutual screws of gene groups and their
dependency
can be inferred jointly from observed
mutation profiles okay with that again I
would like to thank Catalina jack and
mutations but how can you be sure like
do you have any sort of assessment of
the robustness of that tree yeah I mean
we do we do both or let's say we do
either on the maximum like you would
approach or with the MCMC we can sample
from the posterior so you have a full
sample of the posterior when you can
look at any property of the trees that
you want right in terms of stability of
the tree that's what you're asking right
yeah
they tell I mean it's difficult we
looked at free eggs and there's not so
much data around at this point but we
looked at three or so examples and
imitation tree tends to be it tends to
be very stable except of course for
these blocks that we cannot resolve
anyway yeah
I mean the answer is of course it
depends right how is how you simulate
we're simulating with different levels
of noise and different sizes and then
how many cells do you have like I can
show you the simulations let's say we
did that of course I mean in this order
where you have I don't know 20 30 40
mutations and then if you if you have
already twice as many cells it starts to
make sense let's say let's say you're
good you're good shape already but there
we sample trees at random so you can
argue how good that is
I mean you know the simulation is you
take some hot spots yeah that's a very
good point and we are not so confident
in the infernal sites assumption and in
fact we started looking at relaxing the
model not to make that assumption and it
seems like you do even in these data
sets you do find some indication of
violations so I think that's one of the
next big steps to relax that assumption
absolutely everyone in the back first
it's clearly very a very complicated
model to both fit the pathways and
the progression and how much additional
yeah that's that's I mean to really
answer that is is I don't know but let's
say because you know you would need some
ground truth and to say how much better
so validation is for a victory for both
of these models is difficult but what we
have done at least here is maybe let's
look at this one so for example this the
the way we start this procedure is that
we learn these mutual exclusivity groups
independently and then we just learn the
dependencies so using the two approaches
I showed in the beginning independently
one after the other that's the first
thing you can do and then you can
compare and then we start iterating and
you can compare that initial solution
with the final solution you get by
iterating and and they are of course not
totally different but there's a number
of differences between the two so so
meaning that if you take into account
both of these processes or both of these
constraints you get a different answer
than doing it separately that doesn't
that doesn't say that one is right and
the other is wrong but at least you get
a different answer and I think it it
makes sense to combine the two
so you have two sources of terrorists
missing data and being correct data and
I was wondering your simulations what
was the hardest problem was it because
of incorrect data so turns out missing
data it's it's fairly robust against so
I think the the false positive false
negatives are much bigger problem we
also looked at this problem of of duplex
so in the single cell sequencing if you
happen to have two cells rather than one
turned out to be very well yeah fairly
robust against that and also missing
data is not a big problem that one
example I showed you had 45% missing
data I think this is just the advantage
of having a probabilistic model if you
if you try to do that in the exact
formulations of perfect vulajin II for
example you know things that it'd be
complete pretty soon and it's much more
difficult I think that's a big advantage
of this approach
his problem and what is increase in said
error rate or single cella consequence
and why I didn't get the question say if
what is the difference in the error rate
is increasing or single cell it is on
sequencing right so how much more error
there is in the single cell sequencing
I mean specific experimental single cell
amplification is done - okay I don't
know I'm not an expert for the single
cell sequencing but the datasets we
looked at they were done in a quite
different fashion and the quality is
also quite different on the on these two
datasets I showed you so the one from
the never NAB lab uses this nuke seek
technique it seems to work much better
and they hadn't used that in in this
earlier paper from 2012 I mean the way
the way I see it is that this technology
is still quite recent and there's
probably a lot of room to improvement I
think it will become much better but I
cannot give you a quantitative answer
how much more errors are there in a
single cell sequencing experiment as
composed to a box sequencing experiment
maybe someone has a more precise idea
but the way I see it is that there's a
lot of development right now it will
continue to improve for now it's mainly
increase in cell rate and structural
so great okay well even better okay good
let's say I think knee caught you